yes dm arya that's orientary maybe
you think so no this it's not
it's a joke it could be in it's an
inside joke that we have
his name is aryantari i think justin
before
okay all right paul
yes back to the good stuff
yes knight
oh marshall scott had to get sucked and
it would have been proud
all right so he plays pawn
he certainly would not have been very
proud i know
bishop
fun
fun
night
yeah it's coming don't worry
a pawn oh you can't say it now
but
certainly can
we have a great position now yes night
night yes
this is looking extremely ugly for
gmario
it is maybe it's not a gm after all i
think it's uh it's a poser
that's an ugly move that is an ugly move
knight yes
i saw that one at least i saw that one
that's night right
good night good night
oh that's a good bar and a good bar
yes absolutely yeah okay that was that
was actually pretty nice
yeah that was actually really nice i'm
enjoying that oh that was pretty good
nice okay i said that we're gonna we're
gonna play a couple more games but
there's nothing that's gonna top this